[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii irene s was born in 1925
in bergani or zajani in galicia now
ukraine
and was raised in grujons poland irene
was the prisoner of the belly stock
ghetto and later of several
concentration camps
including majdanek treblinka and
auschwitz
irene was a slave laborer in germany and
was liberated by the americans
in counts by the time the war broke out
irene was an accomplished
singer-songwriter
in her testimony she recalls singing
existing songs
and composing new ones together with her
young fellow prisoners
from poland and the soviet union while
irene's native language was polish
she co-wrote this song with a
russian-speaking boy
as they were transported from bialystok
ghetto to majdanek
by the way of treblinka the song
manifesto of the enslaved children
was created in the genre of the heroic
military march
in the minor key which was quite typical
for the protest and resistance songs of
the era
it's uh oh i don't know if i could
uh sing it now just try
and
[Music]
[Music]
this is just a verse and what does it
mean
this is in russian that a
world wide storm is embracing this world
and
people's blood is being shed all over
and yesterday's three children
we're today's
we're today's
uh war prisoners prisoners of war
or today's slaves really the best
translations we're
today we are a bunch of slaves and it
goes on
uh we are we broke we are
kept apart from the rest of the world
and
locked in this ghetto and we are
beaten with a
nazi stick
but if today life is bad for us
we are still hoping for a better
tomorrow well all of those songs were
always like this
can you sing that part about the hope
that you had
the reason for it to was written written
in russian was
that the boy who wrote the words didn't
speak any yiddish
and so we had a choice of polish or
russian so we wrote it in russian
[Music]
mom
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
many people when they think of the
ghettos in eastern europe
mistakenly regard them as
being only uh holding pens
for the death camps or
anti-chambers to the concentration camps
but in fact these ghettos were still
uh communities in their own right
uh on the one hand uh
they were still shaped to some degree or
other by pre-war values
by pre-war memories by pre-war social
customs
and relationships and on the other hand
they were dealing with unprecedented
uh oppression now in the pre-war
communities the jews had newspapers
they had radio uh in the ghettos
uh access to these forms of
social interaction and communication
were terribly limited
and what took their place to a very
large degree were songs
and singing became a basic
uh a medium a a basic
uh type of ghetto interaction
street singers were very popular just
take a look at yankaler
in the lodge ghetto uh people
sang together uh
singing together expressed hopes
fears they expressed the trauma of loss
if you lost a child or a husband
uh a song could uh
not only express your own uh
uh injury your own hurt
but the people who are singing that song
with you
let you know that they've suffered uh
the same loss
and they are experiencing
what you're experiencing one of the key
features
of ghetto life was the constant
contraction of the distance
between the individual and the
collective
what happens to me in the ghetto will
probably happen to us and what happens
to us will probably happen to me
there were different kinds of ghetto
songs
one a very common kind of ghetto song
was the inverted uh pre-war
lullaby or folk song a
uh tune that everybody knew a lullaby
that
everybody remembered uh would be sung
but with different words uh expressing
the stark
contrast between the before
and the now uh a lullaby
like rajin kasmit mandlin raisins and
almonds
which mothers would sing to their
children uh
hoping that they would grow up to
be not only learned in torah but a
proficient and wealthy merchant
lullabies which talk about how daddy
is going to come home and he is going to
bring gifts for
all of us these words were now changed
to express the fact that what what we
have
now is uh uh is is absolutely
uh different from what we used to have
uh in one lullaby
in the lodge ghetto the words are
nishiken
we don't have raisins we don't have
almonds
our father did not go out to trade in
fact our father
is gone we may never see him again
so this was one kind of ghetto song then
there were beggar songs
in the warsaw ghetto for example
i'm not giving up my ration cards i want
to survive
there were parodies uh
sarcastic criticisms of the udenrap
and the jewish police in the villenego
especially uh many of the songs
were connected to the cabaret and the
theater
the vilna ghetto was had many gifted
songwriters
like uh cassriel breida
and leigh brosenthal and uh
the cabaret the ghetto theater were very
very popular
and some of these songs uh were
very quickly picked up by everybody a
song like moisha halsey
sung to an american ragtime beat
expressing
the hope that you got to get out of here
it's going to change just hold on don't
get depressed
a song like pesha fundraiser pesha's a
17 year old girl
she's lost her parents but uh
she's not going to give up hope she can
uh
find her way any anywhere she's not
going to let herself
uh get depressed there's a song yes
yes about a tough little kid who's lost
his mommy and daddy
but nonetheless nobody's going to push
him
around and then finally
we have the kind of song that irene
shapiro
wrote these are what i would call
part of the general genre of partisan
songs
they radiate defiance and
resistance they
stress the con the contrast between
the ghetto today and a better life
uh tomorrow uh these are not
songs of despair or or nostalgia
they're not particularly jewish
instead they seek to leap over
the walls that separate jews from
non-jews
and reiterate faith in a better world
after
the war is over and it also reminds us
something that is very often forgotten
that in the war the ussr
for jews in the east european ghettos
was in fact
the only hope great britain had betrayed
the jews with the white paper
uh ending its promises to the zionist
movement
this happened in 1939 uh the united
states was indifferent
and there was a natural desire
to think that the red army would come
in time to liberate them there was a
natural hope that stalin the great
leader
uh would emerge as the only person in
the world
who could defeat the nazi war machine
you could argue that this was engaging
in illusions and
wishful thinking but what other choice
did they have now irene shapiro herself
is an amazing woman uh
her family came from east galicia
which was a mixed polish ukrainian and
jewish
area but they moved to uh
gru jones a town in northwestern poland
near
gdansk or danzig uh and that's where she
grew up
it was a town with a large jewish uh and
it was a town with a large german
population
where there were very few jews she did
not grow up speaking yiddish she grew up
speaking uh polish her father was a
respected music teacher
uh by all accounts it was a very uh
happy family but with the rising tide of
nazism among the local germans
uh the family pulled up stakes and moved
to bialystok in 1938 bialystok was a
very different
kind of community it was a
a city where the jews were a majority of
the population
where the jews spoke mainly yiddish but
the family seems to have landed on its
feet
her father was able to pick up his
career
as a a as a teacher
and uh after a short german occupation
in september 1939
bialystok was taken over
by the soviets until
june 1941 when the germans invaded the
soviet union
and irene shapiro and her parents and
her sister
found themselves in the bialysto
the horrors of the german occupation
began
literally the first day that the germans
came
uh 2 000 jews were herded into a
synagogue
and burned alive thousands of jewish men
were shanghaied off the streets and
shot after the first wave of terror
subsided uh a ballista
ghetto was established which uh provided
a period of relative
stability until february 1943.
as ghettos go the bialous staggered was
not
terrible the uden rot uh enjoyed the
respect of most of the jewish population
it was led by a engineer
ephraim barros who did the best he could
to make sure that people didn't starve
that they didn't dive
epidemics he set up many shops and
enterprises
and he deluded himself into thinking
that this work for the germans might
buy time and save uh the ghetto
there was also a resistance movement in
the ballista led by mordechai tannenbaum
and uh this uh resistance movement
in fact had uh clear
uh ties to uh the uden rob uh
barash gave them money to buy weapons uh
barish had frequent conversations with
uh tannenbaum
and uh uh the uh
udenrot simply asked the resistance
movement
not to do anything that might give the
germans an excuse to liquidate
uh the ghetto and irene shapiro
was part of that resistance organization
uh and uh she was
uh determined to go to the forests
and fight as a partisan but before that
happened
the germans pounced in august
1943 the second major
uh action in the bialystok ghetto
and without informing baraj they began
to deport
all the jews the resistance movement was
taken totally by surprise
and they were determined to fight now
when this happened uh it turned out
that unlike the warsaw ghetto where the
jews
supported the fighters where the jews
built 750 bunkers
in fact it was the civilian support for
the uprising in the warsaw ghetto
the hundreds of bunkers the jews built
which enabled the uprising to last for
30 days
in bialystok none of this happened the
uh young people who were in the
resistance
were totally isolated uh
the jews did not support them
uh they in fact believed
in german promises that they would be
sent to work
and irene shapiro found herself
holding a grenade and not knowing what
to do with it
and a german soldier actually comes over
gently takes the grenade from her hand
and
sends her over to her mother and father
who are waiting to be loaded onto
a train some other young people fight
back but within a day the resistance in
the bialystok ghetto is stamped out
the train that the germans put irene
shapiro's family on
is divided into two sections one section
uh is detached uh when the train comes
to treblinka
and the jews there are are gassed in
fact this was the last killing in the
treblinka
in mid-august 1943 uh two weeks after
the treblinka uprising
and once these bialystok jews were
killed
uh the camp was uh dissolved
the cars that irene shapiro
happened to be in went to maidanic
and uh irene shapiro and her mother were
separated
from their father uh they were
they went through all the horrors of my
donek but luckily
they were deported to another labor camp
before all the jews in maidon were
killed
in november 1943.
irene shapiro survived these um
labor camps lived to see the liberation
uh and then made a life for herself in
the united states
as a teacher in bronx high school of
science and she also had a family
the the song that she wrote
uh is written in russian
it's not written in yiddish uh yiddish
was not irene shapiro's native language
but russian wasn't either
and again i think it shows this
uh uh desire this this uh
tendency to uh put one's hopes
in the power of the soviet union
i want to end this uh talk
by saying that we should judge this song
not by its literary or its musical merit
because it doesn't have a lot of
literary merit
and the song is simply uh the kind of
tomb
that you could hear in any soviet
wartime movie
uh but we should judge this song by
another criteria
it's an example of spiritual and
cultural
resistance in the widest sense of the
term
that when the germans try to crush you
when the germans try to reduce you
to a person without agency without hope
without
initiative singing is one way
to fight back to say no matter where i
am and no matter how terrible my
situation might be
i can still sing i can still write
and that reminds me that on
one level at least i'm still a human
being
thank you
[Music]
you